i
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
hoy nos acompaña isabel santos jefa de
la misión de observación electoral de la
unión europea que ha venido a venezuela
por las elecciones municipales y de
gobernadores gracias por recibir gracias
a vosotros quería comenzar preguntándole
o haciendo un breve resumen de cómo fue
la visita de la misión estos días
durante el proceso electoral en
venezuela cuál es el balance en esta
misión está en venezuela desde el 14 de
octubre
que hemos venido primero con un grupo de
16 expertos después con un grupo de 44
observadores de longo plazo
que hemos añadido más observadores de
corto plazo y en el día de la elección
teníamos 136 observadores desplegados
por todo lo territorio de venezuela que
ha sido una gran operación de
observación electoral
ha corrido muy bien en cuanto a misión
que
acompañamos lo acto electoral que no hay
que poner está en paz sino acto
electoral ni quitar estampas que eso no
es nuestro nuestra metodología de
trabajo que sólo observamos registramos
hacemos nuestras conclusiones
que al final presentamos nuestras
conclusiones y nuestras recomendaciones
en esta fase sólo estamos a presentar
nuestras conclusiones preliminares en
enero febrero presentaremos nuestras
condiciones nuestras conclusiones
finales y ahí presentaremos
recomendaciones
recomendando al país que haga una
reflexión sobre nuestras propias
propuestas propuestas a fin de mejorar
su proceso electoral es así que nosotros
trabajamos fueron 15 años sin venir a
hacer una observación en el procesos
electorales en venezuela
encontraron alguna diferencia de estos
procesos anteriores en los que sí
tuvieron a este proceso de este año
lo que encontramos los cambios han sido
esto la participación de la oposición
también que había estado viejos de esta
participación en los últimos años
lanzini el consejo nacional electoral
que tiene una composición más plural
tres elementos afectos próximos del
partido en poder de dos
que no son identificados con un partido
de poder aunque ha sido indicado por la
sociedad civil en un otro miembro de la
oposición
un grupo que está a trabajar
que nos ha dicho que tienen la mayoría
de sus decisiones son decisiones por
consenso y que han trabajo de consenso
eso es importante y por otro lado en la
certificación también de las máquinas de
votación que ha habido una auditoría muy
completa hecha por académicos que es una
auditoría que nos identifica un grado de
de cómo decirle de confiabilidad en el
funcionamiento del proceso de votación
que existe en este nuestro país nosotros
vinimos aquí primero por una invitación
de este consejo nacional electoral y
también porque se han reunido
condiciones para que participara también
la oposición y escuchando la cara que
era la opinión de varios sectores de en
venezuela que entendían sin importante
que la unión europea diera esta esta
elección y le quiero decir que durante
mi permanencia en venezuela aún más el
día de la elección porque yo también he
ido a observar con todos los
observadores que para mí que para todos
los observadores todos los relatos que
tenemos es de que las personas
y nos hicieran
muchas veces obligadas gracias por estar
aquí gracias por estar aquí y que eso
nos comprobó que de facto el pueblo
venezolano quería la presencia de la
unión europea en esto acto electoral y
eso para nosotros confirma va a ser la
tierra que era nuestra percepción en los
movimientos de venir se puede decir que
ustedes ayer que observaron todo el
proceso electoral el resumen de más o
menos que tienen y de lo que hicieron
el gobierno de venezuela el que está
actualmente arrasó con digamos la
mayoría ganó la mayoría de las
gobernaciones que estaban en esta
elección en disputa para ganar usted
cree que estas elecciones
para los venezolanos quiero que sobre
toda esa información fueron ganadas no
sé si decirlo limpiamente o si decirlo
sin ningún tipo de maniobra yo no no no
no hago ese subtipo d
de cómo decirle no hago este tipo de
de evaluación del acto electoral yo solo
lo que hago es esto no sólo observó el
acto electoral en recuento de las
dispuestas posibles informaciones que
que ocurra o no
y aquel que es la resolución de hacer de
esas reclamaciones no hago ese tipo de
análisis y me digo que nunca comparto en
ninguna
el sistema electoral ningún proceso
electoral ese tipo d
de visión de que se haga nunca se haga
en democracia nunca se hace nunca en
democracia se respetan todos los
intervenientes es muy importante que se
que haya un gran respecto por todos los
intervinientes el gesto no comentó
resultados electorales lo que ha
ocurrido o no nosotros identificamos
diversas cosas que han co que ha
ocurrido que eso son menos positivas que
no son positivas que no son tolerables a
greg una agresión agresión es una muerte
casos de esto de uso de recursos de
estado en campaña casos de
puntos de control d
de lectores y todo esto está advertido
en nuestro informe todo eso está
invertido en nuestro informe es lo
informe es muy más completo completo y
no podemos decir que novato ha sido de
esta forma o de esta forma en una
palabra en dos palabras o calificó
cualificar el acto no eso sería un
análisis muy básica del acto la
información muy completa
de un valor más positivo de un valor más
negativo y ahora que ahora que pegar en
toda esta información
en nuestras recomendaciones y hacer un
camino hacia el futuro eso es lo más
importante y eso lo sentido de estas
misiones es que es observe porque no hay
procesos electorales perfectos en
ninguna parte del mundo
todos los procesos electorales
necesiten necesitan mejorías y por eso
es importante que se tenga en cuenta
nuestras recomendaciones y que los
diferentes sectores políticos la radio
trabajen de forma a mejorar el proceso
electoral es ese objetivo de todas las
misiones de observación electoral y
podría decir si vemos fortalecido el
sistema electoral de venezuela si los
después de esta observación que hicieron
si los venezolanos realmente pueden
confiar ahora en el sistema en el
sistema siempre
los sistemas de votación por todas las
auditorías es confiable
todo esto todo un movimiento que es
necesario mejorar y hay que mejorar hay
que mejorar cómo hay que mejorar en
muchos otros países tal vez aquí más que
en otros tal vez en otros más que aquí
no hay no lo puedo decir hay que mejorar
hay que mejorar
creo que en la oposición participando en
esta elección
digamos que hace que la democracia sea
más fuerte en el país si no solo la
democracia cuando participan todos los
sectores
de la sociedad
eso solo eso es democracia no hay
democracia solo con un interviniente hay
democracia cuando participan todos y es
importante que haya condiciones para que
todos participen porque sólo así se
construye la democracia eso es un camino
que hay que perseguir la unión europea
no tenía las mejores relaciones con el
gobierno del presidente nicolas maduros
que significó para ustedes que los
invitaran a este proceso electoral ha
sido ha sido una invitación para que
observaran nos no no voy a comentar las
relaciones entre unos y otros
que esto para mí es un paso muy
importante que ha sido un paso muy
importante
no puedo decir márquez
muchas gracias gracias por la entrevista
gracias por vuestra indicación hasta
aquí la entrevista de france 24 recuerde
que para sintonizar la nueva mente puede
ir a nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]